what's going on there reject nation greg
and john here today we are going to
watch ourselves the final trailer for
halloween kills we already got tickets
for the movie that's right we're going
to watch this on the big screen people
so keep a look out for our immediate
reaction we're of course going to record
a review right when we're leaving the
theater maybe at the theater if we're
lucky enough to do it there i know it's
coming out on peacock
yep
some of you guys will be like words
you're doing a movie reaction on youtube
because we want to watch in the theaters
and we only do movie reactions for
movies that might get views
not the guaranteed guaranteed big ones
taking candy for you like malignant
ones that are a real tough sound
[Music]
hey
what are you guys doing out here it's
halloween we've been trick-or-treating
are you alone there's a crazy man in a
white mask
[Music]
[Music]
silver shamrock
[Music]
he did a psycho gag there yeah
[Music]
[Music]
um
yes siree
wait other people took over their house
i guess so i'm coming through
oh
oh
[Music]
my god
[Music]
[Laughter]
did we see dr loomis there
it looks like a flash baby oh let me
find that back i think we saw dr lupus
standing right
there is that him unless this is footage
spliced in from an older movie maybe but
i mean can't be the real lubus i mean
it's definitely at least a tribute that
looks exactly like donald pleasance yeah
oh okay well i'm excited to watch this
movie
i'm very excited to watch it yeah from
every one of their early reactions
people are talking about this just being
like a blood vest that is just non-stop
kills it gets to a point where it's a
little absurd just how ridiculously
violent it gets even dead me james is
out there talking about how it seems to
kind of border on rob zombie territory
which is something that we said in the
other trailer that we covered uh but
this really does seem like it's gonna
pack a major violent punch that might
not be scary but it's certainly gonna be
violent it looks yeah and repulsive
demon visceral and repulsive yeah yeah
it's funny for how bad of a rap the rob
zombie halloweens get to see the i think
it's just the redneckness because yeah i
mean this reed's very aggressively
carnage heavy like those movies seem to
want to be the whole thing about the
town is just the most intriguing part
i'm like everyone seems involved they've
gotten everybody grown up who was being
babysat from the first film practically
they're gonna be involved and they're
gonna have like the inherited trauma of
this so well this is a weird shot that i
haven't freeze framed on the one the
loomis because you got what i'm counting
on this one shot alone are six cops
pointed at a very clean mask of michael
myers
so is this like a flashbang no it can't
be a flashback definitely not a
flashback but it doesn't feel like it's
actually within the the movie i don't
know there's something that seems odd
about this shot right like it's his mask
is so clean and it feels like it's
plucked out of the the older movies i
can't tell if this is a is it's a real
series from the new movie or the older
ones and i mean there's even a moment
where there's like the little uh girl
who looks just like danielle harris in
the you know clown car from part four
and stuff and you have the side by side
so i wonder if they are peppering a lot
of this trailer with remember through
legacy and remember maybe images and
moments that we're gonna expand upon
here because while i have seen every
michael movie i don't have like the best
recollection of every single shot where
i can go this movie is part six or
whatever yeah oh yeah no between all
i've seen every halloween movie and
actually out of the main killers between
freddy jason michael halloween is the
only one where i i know for sure i've
seen every one of them but yet even when
they do these side by sides i'm like
don't really remember you
yeah you know this is for the deep cut
fans who watch like every one of them
every year
this looks exciting i get the impression
though that jamie lee curtis is barely
in this movie don't you get that
i feel like she's going to mostly be at
the hospital yeah you know it's like
whenever we see trailer footage of her
she's not really doing much in here and
it seems like they have to real because
what's the third one called halloween
ends yeah because obviously this is not
gonna end in a way where it's the the
last remaining parts of michael myers
like this is this has to end in a way
where you're setting up the one that
have they already shot that one i don't
know the title's already been revealed
i'm under the impression they already
shot it i want to say they maybe did a
back to back or a double up yeah yeah so
it obviously is not going to have a an
optimistic ending and she's not going to
get to watch the life leave his eyes in
this one
you know with his mask off i wonder if
they would let you see his face there
because they're really teasing like
they're gonna let you see his face but i
just don't get the vibe that you would
see his face it could that's become such
an odd thing because you see it in like
the original first movie like we've seen
michael's face a handful of times across
the franchise and i feel like more so
these days that's kind of a no-no for
people so i would be curious and i feel
like for me
i would want to save that because we
already kind of saw him in the first
movie from like behind and side angles
and stuff like that so if we were going
to get it one more time
full on i kind of want to save that for
the last movie like all i want from what
i'm hearing about her like yeah i want
the violence that's what i want i just
want like a bunch of mayhem but i want
it to still be
fun
instead of just mean-spirited yeah
because i'm all for this this next
installment sort of bleeding into what
the halloween franchise ultimately
became because you know they're like
campy and goofy and and ridiculous like
even from the opening killing thing that
they teased here i'm like that's a
little ridiculous he just leaves frame
somehow ran over there psyched about
with him
yeah
yeah it's a little it's ridiculous and
i'm all for it it's just that i wanted
to kind of be a good hybrid from like
what the camp did evolve into versus
what the reboot was because a big part
of rebooting it by just calling it
halloween was to go
those sequels got it all wrong let's do
it right and then if you're gonna go all
the way back to just being ridic like
evolving into the thing you were course
correcting you gotta at least maintain a
sense of fun yeah yeah or maybe take the
best elements of the camp and leave some
of the other ones because i mean they're
they're likeable and enjoyable things
throughout the series but yeah we don't
necessarily need to be going on full
voodoo cult sure but yeah some some kind
of i'm curious as to what is going to
make this halloween movie unique among
them because it seems like this trilogy
wants to be definitive and special and
this trailer definitely looks like it
came out of the last movie but i'm still
waiting for like what is gonna make this
one's punch really land and resonate
what's like the most unique idea that
they've shown us in these trailers for
this movie across all of them is that
the entire town is going to take some
kind of stand and that's about the
newest thing i can think of whereas yeah
the rest of this is reminding me of just
past halloweens both rob zombie and
otherwise yeah it looks really brutal
doubling down on kills and just
gruesomeness
and uh yeah i just want to know what'll
make it now unique from the first film
versus just you know more yeah
we'll have to see guys are you excited
for halloween kills you're gonna watch
it on peacock or are you gonna go to the
theaters and watch it leave your
thoughts down below subscribe click that
bell hit that like button and let's
shout out some patrons
quantity toggle buckle
william bryant phil hire eider chris
lawson marshall thurber care bear in the
garage rosalie taylor swift bao gayle
the craig ferguson jaren wanner not a
gunner book to stack the crook stiff
cliff rodriguez bliss chris busting my
mister from another sister crispy danny
sweep the leg pancakes alex sander the
great beaver lean mean kathleen mayer
olivia one of the dell guys break my
back like bane differently sane what the
hell levitt odell oh my gosh it's
barnes josh thank you guys so much for
being part of our patreon page hopefully
you're enjoying the crap over there
and the crap right here see you soon
[Music]